How fast can a virus spread through a classroom
or office?
The answer might surprise you.
Around two to four hours.
But stick around after the intro to find out
how to avoid it.
Washing your hands often.
I’m really bad at this whole stay tuned
thing.
Hi there, welcome to DNews, I’m Ross Everett.
So, without thinking, when it comes to transmitting
viruses what’s worse, a sneeze or a hand?
If you said “a sneeze” not only are you
talking to a video, but you’re also wrong.
It turns out that when it comes to spreading
disease, hands are actually the quickest way
to disperse bacteria.
A study done at the University of Arizona
showed that a virus could spread from just
one doorknob to an entire building within
a couple of hours.
And I went to the University of Arizona and
I can confirm that those are some big buildings.
Some rooms can become infected quicker than
others, because duh.
Communal rooms like break rooms and bathrooms
and game rooms are most susceptible to virus
spreading because they get the most traffic.
When a hand touches a surface it picks up
between thirty and fifty percent of the organisms
on it.
But don’t go all germaphobe on me, because
most bacteria is actually beneficial and strengthens
your immune system.
But other bacteria like, say, the norovirus,
you might want to avoid.
So, how does the virus get from your hand
to your immune system?
Take your hand off your face.
Some of you right now are like “how did
he know”?
Well, people touch their face about once every
three minutes and THAT’S how it gets you.
Good news is, it’s easy to avoid getting
the viruses into your system by just doing
what every doctor or teacher or parent has
always told you.
Wash your hands, use hand sanitizer, or never
leave your room.
Okay, maybe not that last one.
Unlike viruses, the quickest way to spread
a video is by sharing it with your friends,
so go ahead and do that with this.
And be sure to subscribe to DNews for more
gross stories like this one.